scream co-stars courtney cox neff
campbell and david arquette appeared on
the drew barrymore show that's cool
where courtney looked back on her iconic
bangs in the third film in my opinion
that's the best part of that film and
i'm a huge fan of the screen franchise
you might be right you might be right
each scream i would try to come up with
a different look for her that was
just over the top gross or ugly or too
much whether it was
oh well that was the worst i don't want
to i forgot about it
there's nothing worse but that was a big
lesson in life because that will forever
forever be on film and
i
we only had one set one set of bangs and
uh i remember they were cut on the set
you're supposed to have like a thing
that starts back here far back and
that's where the part goes for the banks
for some reason someone put it here and
started cutting and i went well i don't
have a choice now
i think yeah i remember that day because
we were all like no they're good really
the highest boys